hast du zufällig eins dieser Videos bei
uns
entdeckt wir haben ja so ein Kanal auf
Youtube der heißt klickzoom und da gibt
es Videos genau und ein Teil der Videos
nennen sich
Fragenlotto und da zeige ich unserem
Gast immer dieses Glas das ist unsere
losrommel mit furchtlosen und harmlosen
die furchtlosen für die muss man
furchtlos sein weil es gemeine
hinterhältige unterstellende Fragen sind
die harmlose sind ganz seicht lieb nett
du kannst wählen du kannst blind ziehen
du kannst so viel zu ziehen wie du
willst du hast die freie Auswahl wie auf
der kmis bitte schön mit Liebe gemacht
was denkt ihr würde ich jetzt
nehmen
sowas muss sein muss sein ich öffne das
mal bin ich echt gespannt ne
ja s natürlich ungerechte
Unterstellungen drin
wann entscheidest du dich mal Comedian
showan oder einfach nur
Selbststeller wann ich mich entscheide
ich sag mal
so gar nicht weil ich bin vom Ding her
Entertainer und Entertainer machen alles
was ih Spaß macht ich leg mich gar nicht
fest in ein Richtung aber ich fin das
braucht man auch nicht aber als
Entertainer müsstest du eigentlich Z
noch tanzen lernen ich kann tanzen
ehrlich ich kann wirklich tanzen guck
mal Menschen
hi tatsächlich
und singen singen muss ein Entertainer
auch oh Gott singen ist bei mir ganz
schlimm also wenn man mich einmal singen
hört würde ich kein raten Entertainer
alles außer singen wärst du all singen g
solange Autotune ist ja da das hilft ja
immer aber nicht live nee ja stimmt n
einmal so liebesding genau machst du
immer Aufzeichnung und dann Playback z.B
haben Milli Vanille auch gemacht ja
absolut genau hab ja gesehen Wasus
geworden ist ja eine lebt nicht mehr dem
anderen geht's auch nicht so gut was
macht dich so
erfolgreich ich denke ich mich macht so
Erfolg ach das ja war eine
liebefage ich denke mich macht
erfolgreich dass ich mich nicht
verstelle dass ich mich so zeige wie ich
bin und im Prinzip auch bin wie die
anderen und manche Leute sich in mich
Wiedersehen so sagen so hey das so B ich
auch hier hier kleiner Penis habe ich
auch z.B ne mach mich erfolgreich ich
denke so weil ich so bin wie ich bin und
das mich nicht verstellt
gut
okay hab voll Angst irgendwie zurecht
ja wann machst du endlich gute Videos
ayi also das war jetzt eine haterfrage
ne die finden ja deine Videos alle MA
ich endlich gute Videos ich sag mal so
gute Videos von von mir die kann man gar
nicht bei mir erwarten ich ma nur
Scheiße hallo meine Videos sind so
schlecht das kriegt nicht mal 10 000
views nur mehr nur ein bisschen aber
mein wann mache ich gute Videos gar
nicht alles schlecht alles schlecht ich
mag sie selber nicht gut
okay diese roten Fragen sind echt cool
ja das Schöne ist ich stell es ja nicht
selber ne also du kannst mir nicht
vorwerfen ich würde dir unterstellen du
machst schlechte Videos bestimmt
schreibst du sie so
auf zum Teil ja zum Teil kriegen wir
aber auch von den Usern Tips frag den
doch mal das und das wie gehst du mit
deiner Arroganz
um ich bin ja echt extrem arrogant also
ich bin ja eh der beste ich meine ich
bin
hallo gemt hallo allein guck mich an
also ich gehe mit mein aranz gut um wie
man weiß bin ich ja eh der beste ja nee
Spaß ich
find ich WK vielleicht auch manche Leute
arrogant aber bist Du gar nicht Ding her
wenn man mich kennt weiß man ich bin es
gar nicht ich kann sogar mich selber
lachen ich mache mich selber selber zum
Affen deswegen aber ganz bei mir gar
nicht
gut hast jetzt sehr viel rote gezogen
genau noch mal eine liebe
Frage
oh wie süß woher nimmst du deine
kreativen Ideen das war jetzt die
ausgleichende Frage zu arogan ja den
schlechten Videos nein den schlechten
Videos ja stimmt stimmt woh nämlich
meine kreativen Ideen
m die kommen manchmal eigentlich kommen
alle meine Ideen einfach so ich bin z.B
in der Schule oder ich sitze in der Bahn
oder Bus hör Musik und dann sehe ich z.B
irgendwas und Bo habe ich eine Idee für
ein neues Video oder einfach meistens
ist es so sogar dass ich in werend ich
Videos drehe Ideen bekomme für andere
hatte ich gerade jetzt letztens also
Ideen kommen immer einfach so ich denke
mal da gar nicht groß über nach das ist
gut du bist gesegnet J
glücklicherweise
ohala was macht dich so unwiderstehlich
ähm ja wie soll ich darauf antworten
weiß ich gar nicht du sollst es doch
langsam wissen du bist alt genug also
ich weiß nicht
also nee jetzt mal ehrlich
unwiderstellig ich finde mich vom Ding
her selber nicht unwiderstellig wenn
Mädchen das sagen wo bleiben die warum
kommen die nicht zu mir ich also falls
irgendein m mich unwistelllich find soll
sie sofort zu mir kommen wirklich ja ist
es so hast du eine Freundin nein hast
keine Freundin haben die Mädchen
vielleicht zu viel Respekt vor
dir oder bist du doch ein kleines
Arschloch
ähm ich kann wirklich Arschloch sein sag
ich wirklich sag ich ernst ich manchmal
ich bin gern frech so Mädchen aber so
aber auch immer so eh spaßig also dass
die wissen nicht meist nicht eh ich
verletz nicht oder so
aber sonst oder kannst dich nicht
entscheiden nein das ist wirklich gar
nicht so viele denken so auf den ich
habe echt extrem viele Mädchen aber es
sind gar nicht so vi sind vielleicht
zwei hen 100 höchstens weißt du sind gar
nicht so viel da kann man mit
zurechtkmen
perfekte perfekte gegenfrage was macht
dich so
unausstehlich ja was man mcht
unaustillig ja ich bin nervig ich
bin nervig kan nervst du manchmal die
Leute ja ja ja kann ich nerv se ich ner
auch gerne ich ner aus Provokation sogar
ich irgendwie weiß so okay ich ner dann
hänge ich immer noch so ja immer das ist
aber natürlich ich weiß wie gesagt ich
weiß wann Schluss ist und wenn ihr das
nicht
aus wie gesagt entweder mag man mich mag
mich nicht und aber ich Ärger beide
Person ich Ärger die Leute die mich
mögen und ich Ärger die Leute die mich
nicht mögen also ist nicht gut aber da
hat man schwer eine Freundin zu finden
die wollen lieb gehabt werden ich habe
viele Frauen lieb also
wenn ich kann ganz lieb sein ich bin
sogar Gentleman obwohl man das nicht
kann Tür aufhalten ja so Mantel
reinhelfen ja soll sie mir echt alles
machen
alsochen okay ja das mit Freundin und
ihr könnte schwer
werden okay aber ich glaub es nicht das
Freunde bekommen das ist schwer
nein ich weiß nicht wä cool wenn nicht
woher kommt dein Erfolg
m woer komm me
erfolk aus einer strickten Planung und
die Planung geht noch weiter und zwar
werde ich die welterrschaft an mich
reißen oh ja ihr glaubt mir nicht aberin
bald bin ich König der Welt nein Spaß ne
wo kommt deine fol ganz
ehrlich ich denke mal ist es so dass ich
halt mich zeige wie ich bin und das
spricht die Leute an dass sich ein Typ
da zeigt der einfach so ist wie er ist
sich nicht verstellt manchmal Scheiße
baut
und ich denke das das was die Leute
sehen wollen vielleicht meche nicht aber
die der größte Teil auf J Fall schon
hast du noch bist du nur bei Youtube
unterwegs oder hast du noch so
unterstützende Maßnahmen Twitter
Facebook oder sonst was ich hab alles
was man sich vorstellen kann ich habe
twitter facebook Schüler VZ studie vz
Mein VZ wer kennt wie lcalist die ges ja
aber das ich bin größenteils nur bei
Twitter Facebook
und sch bin ich nicht mehr dazu kann ich
dir was sagen zwar habe ich mal ein
schülerfet Video kennst das von mir
sinlos fin ich super hat jetzt schon
über eine Million Views und ich habe
mein eigenes Schüler Profil rechts
eingedingst und ich habe so viele
freundscha Fragen dass ich der Server
zusammenbricht wenn ich auf meine eigene
Seite gehen will also wenn ich auf Home
gehe dann bricht das zusammen um Leute
zu anzunehmen muss ich so ein extra Link
den Link selber eingeben nein doch und
dann steht da irgendwie ich habe gerade
irgendwie hört sich vielleicht krass an
irgendwie 230 000 offene
Freundschaftsanfragen bei
SchülerVZ wie soll ich die annehmen man
kann da nicht automatisch annehmen muss
immer einzeln klicken immer Einzel
klicken und das ist ja klar dass ich das
nicht machen kann weil aber da echt
extrem das ist eine gute Seite aber ich
kann sie nicht mehr benutzen weil es tut
mir so
leid ja richtig tragisch ja ist lustig
lustig also bei Facebook geht's Facebook
geht auf jeden Fall da kann man aber
auch leider nur ich habe gerade neuen
Account gemacht weil ich auch da zu
viele Freunde hatte da sagt echt sagt
Facebook sagt echt tut mir leid der nutz
hat so viele Freunde g ich GLB da ist
5000 die ganze bei Facebook ja irgendwie
so Fans Seite machen dann habe ich auch
habe ich gerade gemacht jetzt also
können alle gerne aufgehen ja Beil Fan
da muss man nicht bestätigen einfach
klack klack klack auf like oder so ne ja
also ich hab jetzt ein also hab sogar
ein eigenen App jetzt nein wie geht das
denn ja das war ganz einfach eigentlich
irgendwie so App so heißen die mach ich
hab gesehen Shane Dawson Mystery getarm
alle
bekannten Youtuber aus Amerika haben so
ein App dachte ich mir h wieso haben die
App Blabla hab mich informiert dann ja
jetzt habe ich ein eigenes nächste Frage
sind dir die Ideen
ausgegangen ausgegangen sage ich mal
nicht weil das Ausgehen geht gar nicht
weil Ideen kommen immer wieder neue ich
habe sogar etliche Ideen die ich einfach
für special Dinge aufhalte wo ich
okay ich sag mal ich erinnere an so ein
Video wie der beste Shar Norris Witz
ja das Video war ich sag mal so ich
dachte jetzt jetzt kommt was aber ja nee
nee nee dazu kann ich auch da bei den
Videos also mit den ganzen tagesvideos
ist wirklich gib ich zu ich hatte keine
Idee manchmal aber ist klar wenn man
jeden Tag ein Video macht ist klar dass
irgendwann Scheiße rauskommt
und da sind mir auf jeden Fall Ideen
ausgegangen aber die richtigen Ideen Hal
ich mir für mein richtigen count hin was
wo viele Leute das nicht verstehen weil
ich habe halt Haka Germany 2 aber ha 2
ist halt nur so Tagebuch wie bla und das
hier die richtig und da kommen auch die
ganzen Ideen der der ist cool hier okay
und zum Abschluss zur Versöhnung okay
die allerletzte sogar eine liebe ich bin
gespannt was ist das Geheimnis deines
Erfolges
erstmal Ich mag voll das Wort Erfolg
irgendwie das ist echt cool weil
manchmal realisiert man halt selber
nicht so was man geschafft hat wenn ich
jetzt gucke
ich hatte vor paar Monaten noch 10 000
ich habe mich gefreut wie Sau als ich 10
000 erreicht habe und jetzt habe ich
schon jetzt habe ich schon irgendwie 110
000 oder so und das sind selber so wenn
ich so überlege vorher habe ich Leute
angeguckt die hatten 60.000 ich dachte
so ich habe mich haben Leute
angeschrieben sie haben 60 000 gehabt
damals 80.000 die mich angeschrieben ich
war voll glücklich jetzt habe ich
sozusagen ich habe sogar Leute die ich
selber gefeiert habe schon überholt be
meinen Abonnenten und das ist echt krass
also Erfolg kann man es nennen was ist
das Geheimnis daran un das Geheimnis ist
Geheimnis gibt es gar nicht
also ich habe kein Geheimnis ich habe
vielleicht eine Strategie aber die ist
geheim die ist geheim deswegen ist es
die geheime Strategie okay das Geheimnis
bleibt geheim das Geheimnis bleibt
geheimer als die Geheimnis beim
Geheimbund oh oh oh der nicht cool der
ist ziemlich geheim aber das bleibt
unter uns das bleibt geheim ne okay
diger ich danke dir cool L